[Musique]
étienne qu'un bonsoir vous recevoir une
chaîne youtube une chaîne internet qui
diffuse en direct qui s'appelle think ur
view on vous reçoit en tant que
philosophe peut-être physicien comment
allez vous c'est là pas mal est-ce que
vous pouvez nous faire une petite
présentation rapide de guidage poncet
habitait tout près de chez vous plutôt
je pensais que votre studio était tout
près de chez moi et c'est en sortant de
chez moi je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais confondu de rue la rue gergovie
et la rue gassendi donc j'ai couru ça je
vois pas trop voilà je parlais des frais
et bien je suis directeur de recherche
au commissariat à l'énergie atomique et
aux énergies alternatives
qu'est ce que vous entendez par énergies
alternatives alors ça serait une très
bonne question c'est ce qui est 10 ans
non nucléaires et non fossiles je pense
à ce que est ce que c'est pas un peu du
greenwashing
ah non c'est pas renouvelable
tout non parce que d'abord il n'y a pas
d'énergie renouvelable comme vous savez
il avait fini l'adc la loi de
déperdition énergétique pas du tout
c'est quelle énergie conserve la boîte
déperditions d'énergie non pas du tout
c'est la loi de conservation l'énergie
energy sse conserve c'est à dire que si
vous prenez un système au début et à la
fin il ya la même quantité d'énergie
si c'était si le système est d'isoler de
sorte que l'on peut pas
consommer d'énergie en fait elle est
tout le temps là il y en a autant à la
fin qu'au début si vous roulez en
voiture par exemple
vous mettez à l'idée sens dans l'autre
ces réservoirs ya d'énergie qui est
concentré sous forme chimique en
l'occurrence vous rouler ça fait de
l'énergie cinétique vous allumez vos
phares vous chauffer l'atmosphère vous
chauffez la route et à la fin il ya
autant d'énergie qu'au départ vous allez
simplement transformer sa forme donc ya
pas de consommation d'énergie ont
produit de l'entropie y en est on crée
de l'entropie quand on dit qu'on
consomme de l'énergie
et de même y'a pas les énergies
renouvelables puisque
quand vous avez consommé entre
guillemets acquis le water d'énergie
solaire par exemple vous l'avez
consommer ce qu'ils renouvelables c'est
la source mais pas l'énergie elle même
est ce que est ce que vous avez
discussions avec les politiques
concernant la dispersion énergétique
la dispersion la transition la
dispersion et puis après peut-être la
transition pour moi j'ai participé à de
loin au débat sur la transition
énergétique et jeu en effet j'ai parfois
écrit dans des articles qu'elle a un
problème de vocabulaire
et que si on dit des choses qui ne sont
pas conformes aux lois physiques on
glisse que de dire des choses qui
n'auront jamais une réalité la nature ne
peut pas être dupe et comme disait le
prix nobel de physique l'écharpé yann et
donc par exemple l'énergie on peut pas
en produire
alors que nous on parle de temps en
temps parler en tout cas de production
d'énergie peut pas reproduire puisque
justement elles se conservent donc on
peut pas la créer à partir de rien
autrement dit pour en avoir il faut déjà
en avoir
et une fois qu'on en a alors on peut
soit la transférer transféré du système
où elle se trouve vers un autre système
soit changé sa forme change et une forme
j'ai pas électrique en énergie thermique
ou autre chose mais on peut pas la créer
la produire à partir de rien on a un
vocabulaire qui lance le laisse entendre
que ce serait possible pourquoi pourquoi
se travestir la langue française m parce
que d'abord on nomme pas toujours dire
les choses les montants sont les
expressions se sont rencontrés dans nos
façons dire dans la culture même il est
très difficile de les extraire et de
revenir à une police du langage d'autre
part les scientifiques n'ont pas
vocation étant là dans la dans la police
du langage justement
pour critiquer le langage mais pas
imposer des façons de dire
pas faux pour vous
est-ce qu'on peut se livrer une petite
expérience de pensée
j'adorerais essayons d'aider capable
d'un des meilleurs pour ça non
cette société énergétique de
transformant
si le politique ne voit pas le bon
vocabulaire pour soutenir son économie
le scientifique a qu'elle roule face à
ça c'est un acteur passif est ce que ça
doit être un lanceur d' alerte est ce
que c'est un objecteur de conscience
ou est-ce qui doit continuer tout seul
dans son laboratoire a cherché tout seul
et à patienter c'est ce qui se passe
autour bon moi je suis l'exemple qu'on
doit sortir du laboratoire les beaucoup
fait trop fait ça n'a pas toujours plu
non on n'échappe pas toujours à ces
mouvements spontanés
ses éclairs de lucidité voilà non moi je
pense que selon la discipline dans
laquelle on travaille on a une mission
vis-à-vis de la société qui peut être
très différente par exemple si on fait
l'astrophysique ou la cosmologie et la
physique des particules
on doit
émerveillé le public en lui montrant que
ce qui nous paraît évident par la
fréquentation du monde empirique dans
lequel on aime le monde macroscopique
disons devient complètement faux dans le
monde microscopique qui est régie par
d'autres lois qui sont très surprenantes
et qui peuvent pas mal excité
l'imaginaire je pense qu'on doit sortir
des laboratoires dans ces cas là pour
nous sortir de nos concepts familier de
nos automatismes de penser de nos
fausses évidences pour nous ouvrir
l'esprit finalement et puis si au
contraire vous donne créée dans le
domaine de l'énergie
ou dans des domaines qui ont plus
d'impact sur la vie quotidienne des gens
alors si tout le contraire il me semble
qu'on a on ne doit pas fait on doit
empêcher les gens de rêver à des
scénarios impossible c'est à dire que
pour la question de l'énergie on a des
lois on connaît et on doit se baser sur
ces lois pour penser le futur ils n'ont
pas imaginer qu'on va découvrir une
nouvelle interaction de nouvelles façons
de produire d'autres formes d'énergie
parce que on ne peut pas construire le
futur de nos sociétés sur des paris qui
sont trop risqués on doit tenir compte
de ce que nous savons qui est solide
dans nos frais de notre façon de penser
est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut
poser des questions d'enfants avec un
cerveau d'adultes pour imaginer le futur
ça dépend des périodes einstein l'a fait
je pense que vous citez einstein là qui
disait en effet qu'il avait à l'âge
adulte avec un cerveau correspondant
poser des questions d'enfants à l'époque
la physique était en crise mais mais lui
le voyait plus que les autres et donc
c'est par ce type de questionnement qui
l'a montré où étaient les contradictions
et comment on pouvait espérer les
réseaux de par des théories
révolutionnaires
relativité en l'occurrence maintenant
aujourd'hui poser des questions
d'enfants
à propos de la physique je passais en
soi très fécond parfois c'est
déstabilisant par exemple
je me souviens d'un jour je vais
vous écrire un livre sur le temps pour
les enfants et du coup je m'étais dit il
faut je pars du questionnement des
enfants
et donc j'avais rendu visite à une
classe de cm2 et j'avais écouté les
questions des enfants
quel âge il avait 7 ans 8 ans si m dos
et 59 ans on sait trop bien
égyptienne une question qui m'avait
scotché et qui ne cesse depuis de me
turlupine et un enfant ma vie mais
monsieur
s'il est vrai que le temps passe
alors ils devraient finir par s'user
donc le temps devrait être victime du
temps où d'exhorter le temps qui passe
devant victime de son propre passage ça
m'avait quand même déstabilisé parce que
le temps de me d'automne par exemple
c'est précisément un temps qui ne change
pas au cours du temps sa façon d'être le
temps mais mais s'il passe alors qu'en
sait-il qui passe tout en restant le
même
et c'était une question finalement très
profond que avait guère traite un peu
dans l'être et le temps vous venez nous
contamine le toucan pourquoi avec votre
question pourquoi parce que ça va
boucler à ça va vous coller c'est à dire
vous allez
reposer la question ça n'a bouclé c'est
une expression entre nous question
d'internet à caen putsch scientifique
un putsch scientifique sur internet nous
a quand un putsch scientifiques face à
la politique face à la société est ce
que les scientifiques vont être amenés à
prendre le pouvoir à quand vous dites
une question internet c'est idiot qui
vous arrive par internet ça n'est pas
une question relative à ce qui circule
sur internet et qui est parfois très
faux pas fou
non ben j'sais pas moi je ne prévois pas
de putsch parce que la science quand
elle est bien pensé bien faite elle
permet de comprendre ce qui est enfin de
comprendre ce qu'on connaît de ce qui
est mais ne dit pas ce qui doit être
et c'est ça qui rend les débats très
compliqué un physicien nucléaire il peut
vous expliquer comment on pourrait faire
une centrale nucléaire par exemple un
réacteur nucléaire ou une bombe atomique
qui peut vous expliquer comment faire
mais il sait pas du tout si on doit le
faire
pareil pour les ogm avec les biologistes
pareil pour les nanosciences
pareil pour la génétique pareil pour les
cellules souches d'état autrement dit
dès lors que nos sociétés ne sont plus
en chasser dans l'idée de progrès qui
était une idée un peu trop son mental
qui donnait un sens à toutes nos actions
présentes qui devait servir à configurer
et réalisé un certain futur qu'on avait
envie de voir advenir
aujourd'hui les débats confronte non
plus non plus des principes et des
valeurs ou des dogmes ou des dogmes ou
les valeurs mais les valeurs sont moins
universel que les principes parce que la
valeur d'une valeur elle dépend des
évaluateurs donc quand on commence à
discuter de ces débats les gens
s'opposent et il n'y a aucun moyen de
réaliser un consensus
puisque toute valeur peut se prétendre
avoir une valeur qui la rend accompagné
d'autres valeurs qu'on met en face
regardez l'histoire de annoncé
aujourd'hui de l'abandon de l'aéroport
de notre dame des landes
bon il ya une décision qui a été prise
mais c'est évident qu'il y ait pas de
bonnes décisions pour que ceux qui sont
pour ont des arguments assez solide
qu'elle ceux qui sont contre ont des
arguments à sa solide et donc et donc
tranché dans ce contexte là
c'est
je trouve très difficile parce que
avant la décision vous êtes forcément si
vous avez une certaine ouverture
d'esprit vous êtes dans un état
quantique et vous êtes dans la
superposition de a et b a + b a et b et
en deux états possibles du système sauf
que prendre une décision c'est casser
cette somme pour réaliser soit soit mais
au passé de a + b indétermination aa ou
bien b
lâchement dur
comment et par exemple prenez un autre
quart qui est retranché aussi par
gallimard ya pas très longtemps est ce
qu'on doit publier les manifestes de
céline antisémites de céline
moi je vous avoue je me suis pas
beaucoup intéressé au dossier je les ai
pas lues ce dernier j'ai lu des articles
sur cette question et j'ai été surpris
de lire un article était pour aussitôt
après j'ai lu un article qui étaient
contre
et j'étais d'accord avec les deux
gpu et décider
de la complexité c'est justement
admettre que les questions ne peuvent
être résolus de façon radicale que si on
se réfère à un dogme mais si on les
prend dans leur complexité alors il ya
des cas c'est vraiment pas simple et le
choix est quasiment remis traire vous
avez des dogmes ou
et d'hommes
dans la vie
je sais pas ce qu'on peut appeler ça des
deux bords j'ai pas de dogme
j'ai des connaissances sur
sûr je pense que on est allé trop loin
dans l'idée que
toutes les connaissances que nous avons
sont relatives à une culture à un moment
de l'histoire un contexte
l'idée que toutes les connaissances
peuvent de se défendre dans des terreaux
qui leur donnent du sens que tout les
relative pour le dire de façon brutale
c'est une idée qui nous a fait je trouve
beaucoup de mal et qui sait que les
croyances et les connaissances ne se
distingue plus bien les uns des autres
d'autant plus qu'elle circule dans les
mêmes canaux dans internet dans les
médias circulent des opinions des
croyances des connaissances
défectueuse comme dirait l'autre elles
se mélangent et se contaminent de sorte
que il est important qu'on
[Musique]
permette de distinguer les connaissances
des croyances comment fait on alors
comment faire
très bonne question
si à mon avis pour l'instant la bataille
est mal engagée c'est pour deux raisons
la première c'est que les gens qui ont
des croyances en général sur plus
prosélytes que ceux qui ont des
connaissances
dont qui s'activent davantage
et la deuxième raison c'est que nous
avons tous beaucoup de connaissances
notamment scientifique on sait que la
terre est ronde
on sait qu'elle tourne autour du soleil
qui lui-même tourne autour du sang dès
la galaxy la galaxie tourne autour d'eux
d'autres galaxies et ya pas de 137 est
bon c'est tout ça on sait que l'univers
est en expansion
on sait que les espèces évoluent bon
bref
maintenant ses connaissances si on nous
demandait
d'expliquer comment dans l'histoire des
idées elles sont devenues des
connaissances
on s'est embrassés par exemple comment
ce qu'on a su que la terre était ronde
et quand
on la suit ya très longtemps aristote le
savait avec quels arguments
qu'elles étaient les arguments qu'ils
pouvaient opposer à ceux qui pensent que
la terre était plate ou avait la forme
d'un disque
aujourd'hui on a les photos de la terre
depuis 1936 des photos prises de
l'espace est très curieusement 1956 qui
est l'année on voit que la terre est
ronde on le voit vraiment on la voit
entièrement ronde si je veux dire c'est
aussi l'année où les américains crée
l'association des amis de la terre plate
et donc
faut interroger ça
mais si vous n'êtes pas capable de dire
grosso modo comment cette connaissance a
pu se bâtir comme reconnaissance
devant des gens qui ont la croyance
opposez
vous allez être fragile et donc le
problème c'est ce qui fait que la
bataille pour l'instant est mal engagée
c'est que nous avons une mauvaise
connaissance de connaissances nous ne
savons pas ce qui les a distingué dans
l'histoire des idées des croyances et
c'est pour ça que moi je milite elle
c'est pas un dogme en et je milite pour
que
toutes les périodes de la vie scolaire
chaque année on raconte aux élèves
l'histoire en détail d'une découverte
entendant les arguments pour contre
comment ça s'est passé dans l'histoire
et on raconte la véritable histoire pas
des bulgares qui en général simplifier
les choses ceux qui sont contre une
connaissance où il a contest en général
ont des arguments et l' arbitre c'est
ils ont la nature ou bien le réel qui un
jour il ya d'apporter un élément qui
fait qu une position qui était tenable
jusqu'à ce moment-là ne l'est plus
ça est compliqué cette interview
pourquoi
beaucoup de choses qui a longtemps
les politiques qui vous êtes amené à
côtoyer
10 envisagent des solutions à court
terme à moyen terme deuxième question
juste à la suite comment vous voyez
l'avenir de nos sols de nos sociétés
avec le contexte actuel
lino perros nos politiques à transmettre
on va dire la vérité de la connaissance
ou à stabiliser l'opinion publique par
rapport à des choses ferme qu'est ce
qu'on fait elle semblait pas de moi que
je parle des politiques en général n'a
aucun sens politique compte en tout
genre connaît quelques-uns il ya là que
je connais directement d'autres que je
connais comme tout le monde les connaît
j'en connais deux remarquables j'en
connais deux par remarquable ils sont
comme tout le monde
une résistance quand même aux attaques
est supérieure à la moyenne et par an
qui sait des coupons navy plus
plus sereinement que beaucoup d'entre
nous donc j'ai aucun jugement général
sur les politiques d'autre part c'est
pas à eux de transmettre les
connaissances scientifiques ils sont pas
là parce qu'ils sont professeurs non
mais celui qui détermine le budget de
l'éducation nationale par exemple mais
c'est nous qui payons les impôts est ce
que vous payez vos impôts bien sûr si ce
budget était trop important est ce que
ceux qui paient les impôts ne dirais pas
qu'il est trop important donc c'est
compliqué on est tous partie prenante de
cette affaire à la fois dans le fait
qu'on les partis prônant une politique
et en même temps dans le fait qu'on la
juge bonnes ou mauvaises
donc je pense que
le politique c'est celui qui
doit prendre des décisions
y compris lorsqu'elles sont très
difficiles et les assumer et ça c'est
quand même une capacité que tout le
monde n'a pas donc moi je leur rends cet
hommage disons d'être dans certains caps
capable de le faire de trancher les
questions qui parfois très un
train-train 10
seulement d'un certain courage quand
même je connais aussi des politiques
parfaitement lâche donc voyez ce que je
veux retenir n'est pas un discours
général mais
si vous vous permettez je vous parle
franchement
j'ai aimé pendant la can présidentielle
le maquereau parle de l'avenir j'ai aimé
ça
c'était nouveau prêt du progrès dans
l'allée des forces progressistes
alors que les autres étaient dans un
présent 10 mai froids yable est donc ce
que je demande non pas pour moi qui suis
un homme très mûrs mais pour les
adolescents c'est qu'on réactive
collectivement publiquement et
politiquement un discours sur le futur
je fais partie d'une génération qui
lorsqu'elle était adolescente
donc années 70 pour ceux qui ont besoin
de données chiffrées
dans les années 70 on nous parlait de
l'an 2000 tout le temps quand je dis
tout le temps c'est tous les jours les
voitures volantes à la télévision dans
les magazines pour adolescents autrement
dit l'an 2000 était configuré ils
étaient représentés aux deux sens du
terme il était placé dans notre présent
et ils étaient représentés parce qu'il
était dessinée
illustrée au jasmin secours une
représentation de sorte que chacun
d'entre nous pouvait se projeter
sur une trajectoire quel est le mener de
l'endroit dans le présent nous étions
vers ce futur qui était présenté et ça
donne
une assise pour sa propre projection
dans le futur qui est quand même assez
utile même si la projection il fonce en
partie fausses et des choses qui sont
pas réalisés d'autres qui se sont
réalisés il ya des erreurs dans la
prospective et aujourd'hui qui parle de
2050 qui le configure qui le pensent
alors on dit la société liquide est la
plus de ressort suffisamment ancrées
pour pouvoir faire un prêt des
prédictions solide et des sujets sur
lesquels on faire des prédictions solide
l'énergie le climat et on voit que là ça
coince un peu ça coince mais plutôt que
de dire ça coince donc il faut agir
vraiment on développe entre quand on a
développé pendant longtemps
toutes sortes de stratagèmes
intellectuelle pour ne pas croire ce que
nous savons le déni le déni dont la
seule fonction est la procrastination
et en procrastine ans en aggravent notre
cas
et on le fait tous plus ou moins
consciemment plus ou moins
volontairement mais on le fait
et donc demandé
l'humanité parce que c'est elle qui est
concerné c'est par bout de la société
qui concerne et demandé à l'humanité de
changer comme ça pas de la coop
claquement de doigts parce que de
nouvelles connaissances apparaissent de
nouvelles données apparaissent
ces comportements
c'est pas évident je pense que ça va
être un siècle intéressant là dessus
systémique non c'est un siècle
intéressant parce que nous allons de
plus en plus dépendre de choses
qui ne dépend pas de nous et des lois
philippe qui agissent
et qui sont responsables de l'évolution
du climat et puis à nos comportements
qui change la donne est donc on dépend
de choses qui dépendent de nous et on
dépend de choses qui ne dépendent pas de
nous et 2 saintrick et donc il va y
avoir du sport à mon avis sur la
question de l'environnement des
ressources naturelles les matières
premières de l'énergie et du climat le
démographe y aussi la démographie aussi
des migrations internes
je vous poste ma collègue
est-ce que je ne joue les scientifiques
se font assez entendre face au lobby et
aux scientifiques financés par les
lobbys
alors
je vais faire la même réponse que pour
les politiques au sens où je vais je ne
l'attendais pas de moi je parle des
scientifiques gérard d'abord je ne
connais pas tous
mais j'en connais suffisamment pour voir
et savoir qu'il résiste d'espèces fort
différentes donc je refuse de les mettre
dans le même sac
et les scientifiques
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce sont les gens
qui sont très spécialisés
et qui donc peuvent être retenus par
modestie ou par sentiment de leur
incompétence à parler de tout à donner
des ordres
et sont souvent mis en porte à faux
parce que ya une forme de discours
publics qui lance laisse entendre que
les scientifiques prépare des
révolutions technologiques ou autres qui
sont d'ampleur colossale qu'elles vont
changer la société peut être produire
des
révolutions dans la civilisation on l'a
dit ça à propos des nanosciences par
exemple ans le scientifique et non son
labo qui sépare faire passer un photon
dans un étude de carbone ne voit pas
très bien en quoi ce qu'il fait là peut
avoir des implications et pourquoi il
serait le responsable et devrait assumer
un discours collective dont il n'est pas
l'auteur mais convient fait porter
indirectement
et donc toutes les attitudes sont
possibles et défendable il y en a qui
ont le goût de l'explication de la
pédagogie
et qui comme moi par exemple j'aime
j'aime enseigner donc
j'écris délié je vais au contact de
toutes sortes de publics parce que ça
m'intéresse d'entendre ce que les
publics pensent des scientifiques et de
voir d'ailleurs que que chacun d'entre
nous a un problème avec la science
soit parce qu'elle lui a laissé de
mauvais souvenirs l'école soit parce
qu'il la comprend pas soit parce qu'il
en a peur soit parce qu'elles échappent
un maîtrise par le politique soit parce
que c'est pour tout le monde a un
problème que la science et c'est
intéressant pour un gentil d'entendre
ces questionnements pour en tenir compte
peut-être sa façon d'en parler ensuite
il ya des gens qui sont des militants
qui croit certaines choses certaines
technologies par exemple
pour améliorer les rendements je parle
du photovoltaïque e ou des cellules qui
est ok en conscience d'un problème
scientifique
un problème même environnementale
d'énergie par exemple quand une idée sur
une solution possible qui permettent
d'améliorer une technologie qui voit une
militante cette énergie et on a d'autres
moins nombreux j'espère qu'ils se font
payer par des lobbys pour défend des
thèses
donc tout est possible mais mais la
première responsabilité du scientifique
quand même
c'est de faire la bonne science
ma vie sur le transhumanisme
le transhumanisme on en parle beaucoup
il y en a plusieurs en fait c'est pas
c'est pas un corps de doctrine 13
unifier le transhumanisme si j'ai bien
compris il ya ceux qui descendent
1,3 humanisme qui consisterait à coupler
l'homme avec la machine c'est là c'est
la voix dillon cyborg
on truffe l'être humain le corps humain
de toute sorte d'un plan qu'ils vont
réaliser des fonctions pour les
augmenter pour pallier les déficiences
été pour
doper et augmenter toutes les
performances du corps et de
l'intelligence humaine puis à ceux qui
sont plutôt pour un transhumanisme
génomique on bricole le génome on
améliore
pour empêcher certaines maladies pour
faire des individus qu'ils soient mieux
adaptés au monde tels qui s'annonce
alors dans un premier temps moi je vais
penser que le transhumanisme
essayer de fournir
à l'idée de progrès et quand même un peu
moribonde l'occasion d'une rédemption
ils ont finalement l'homme fabriqués par
l'indienne siècle est un être fatigué un
être qui a fait la shoah qui a fait la
bombe atomique qui est en quelque sorte
épuisé d'être lui-même et ils sont il
est temps de se servir de la science
pour le sortir de cette condition est
fabriqué un humain post humain qui
regardera les homo sapiens que nous
sommes invités yeux pleins de
condescendance ou de pitié ou de mépris
on sait pas
et donc je pensais que c'était une
réactivation des idées anciennes mais en
fait quand on les lit on s'aperçoit que
ce qu'ils prévoient ne concerne pas du
tout le genre humain
comme l'imaginait les philosophes des
lumières mais une partie très
petit de l'humanité riesch qui a accès à
des soins de qualité de service à des
technologies qui sont pas à la portée de
tout le monde et qu'en fait le post
humanisme c'est une idéologie non pas du
progrès et de la rupture
il s'agit pas de faire progresser
l'humanité me le rompre avec elle
et là on pourra voir sont moins bien
vous positionnez comme en temps de
sécher eh ben je voulais rompre le chic
antique je suis quantique comme tout le
monde en fait comme presque tout le
monde tout le monde est à déterminer là
dessus
imaginez qu'on dise
voilà on n'a pas droit le bricolage
énorme de quelqu'un si on voit un gène
qui défaillant
alors allez le corriger dans l'embryon
bien éliminer les embryons qui l'ont
un peu se défend tout cas fait
mais si un jour vous avez un enfant est
une maladie génétique
et que lui apprend plus tard qu'il y
avait un moyen d'empêcher qu'il l'est
qu'est-ce qu'il va vous dire quelle sera
votre réaction
ce que je veux dire c'est que les
questions qui sont posées sont des
questions
lors de l'édition éthique et l'éthique
c'est pas il ya un bouquin d'éthique que
je consulte qui me donne les réponses
aux questions que pose par définition
par définition une question éthique
c'est une question qui n'a pas de
solution
c'est pas en lisant les traités de
morale que vous avez deux solutions
c'est pas en lisant quand
que vous avez la solution parce que
quand ils n'imaginaient pas que entre
des choses que lui considéré comme
séparées de façon définitive et la
nature l'artifice l'inerte le vivant
tout ça maintenant s'entremêlent donc
tous les critères de mots on avait
établi en pensant que les frontières
étaient vraiment hermétique et
d'ailleurs sacré tombe il faut en
trouver d'autres et c'est là que la
discussion devient intéressante et aucun
de ces problèmes n'est simple et donc si
on les traite avec des like pas laïque
je suis pour je suis contre ça va pas
aller c'est trop binaire c'est trop
binaire
est ce que aujourd'hui les financements
et la recherche des utilisations
commerciales
prive la recherche scientifique de
hasard et de liberté et de recherche au
final bon moi j'ai connu une période où
les chercheurs ce que veut pas d'argent
on était dans des organismes de
recherche part de la france il y avait
des contrats entre ces organismes de
l'état c'est mary ce ou ces voyages un
contrat il fallait faire des études
échaudé les chercheurs ont étudié ces
choses si l'argent était là aujourd'hui
on est financé sur le projet donc on
doit définir des projets il ya des
projets de recherche fondamentale on
pourrait dire que le financement baisse
selon quels critères ça je voudrais bien
qu'on me le dise ce que je vois moi
c'est qu'il ya jamais eu autant de
recherche fondamentale
qu'aujourd'hui le nombre de papiers de
chercheurs qui sont dans ce secteur est
énorme ce qui m'inquiète c'est que les
papiers sont outre qu'ils sont vraiment
de plus en plus nombreux ils sont de
plus en plus difficile à lire va c'est
peut-être moi qui vis mais des g7 qu'il
ya des papiers vraiment fondamentaux
nouveau sur des sujets qu'ils sont
compliqué c'est long question du temps
par exemple la question des théories qui
vont dans les modèles standards en
physique des particules
ou bien tout bêtement
l'abominable mystère dont parlait meuse
darwin comment comme on les travaille là
dessus en ce moment là je regarde des
travaux là dessus comment sont apparus
les plantes à fleurs
il ya 150 millions d'années alors que
les plantes tout court sans fleurs sont
apparus il ya 200 millions d'années
dans wii ne comprenait pas les fleurs
ait pu apparaître alors c'est assez
complexe la sexualité des fleurs c'est
pu apparaître comme ça tout d'un coup et
pu coloniser la surface de la terre et
proliférer résout très rapide bon je lis
des articles à dieu c'est très compliqué
à lire et donc je me demande si nous
sommes encore capables de pros de
comprendre les connaissances que nous
produisons de les gérer
sans être trop spécialisées d'un sujet
très particulier et donc pour moi plutôt
que la
question de la répartition des
financements entre recherche
fondamentale et recherche appliquée
recherche et innovation développement
brevet d'état pour moi c'est comment
garder une certaine maîtrise
intellectuelle
de nos connaissances j'ai pas envie de
voir arriver le moment où ce sont les
logiciels dits intelligents négligence
ils feront l'analyse des articles et qui
viendront signalé dans ma boite mail le
matin contenu de vos centres d'intérêts
faut dire ça et ça et ça mais rien
d'autre
vous avez un point de vue sur la société
de surveillance par les big data
l'intensité de téléphone bruyère point
de vue là tu moi je suis absolument pour
la protection absolue la vie privée
je supporte pas tous ces
petits accommodements
qu'on tolère au nom de la sécurité si on
aime la liberté si on avait la liberté
on aime on aime c'est pas qu'on supporte
on aime les risques qui vont avec
et moi je n'aime pas les
décisions
qui confondent
deux versions très différentes du
principe de précaution on évoque
toujours le principe de l'érosion dans
les actions qu'on mène dans les
décisions qu'on prend et parfois il
s'agit
de faire baisser les dangers et là le
principe de précaution tel qu'il a été
annoncé et justement provoquer
et parfois il faut au contraire diminuer
l'anxiété
et diminue l'anxiété et diminue les
dangers c'est pas du tout la même chose
c'est pas du tout la même chose
comment vous protéger vous parce que
l'anxiété
elle s'exprime plus ou moins
explicitement ça peut être très
diffusion la rose on recense donc
société la population et il faut prendre
des mesures pour dessiner cette société
est décédé danger
plus efficace non
voilà c'est pour ça que je suis très
protégé comment vous vous vous maintenez
votre jardin secret contre les
ingérences alors écoutez moi je si je
suis un peu ferme là dessus c'est parce
que sans entrer dans les détails mon
jardin secret comme vous l'avez il a été
violée tout savoir pour qui par des gens
qui ont qui ont bricolé mon ordinateur
et ça m'a pas plu du tout les gens
j'étais là pas plus qu'ils vous ont
bricolé à l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur
de chez vous dans un cercle là c'est
assez vaste on peut vous aider c'est
trop dans ses vieilles histoires
mais c'est un truc là c'est maintenant
vous avez mon bureau alors si vous avez
une petite école tout ça alors voilà
j'ai pour l'instant je préfère de
beaucoup la liberté à la sécurité
revenons revenue à un autre physique
comment expliquer que depuis la création
du prix nobel en 1901 on a eu que 46
lauréate féminine sur 821 et surtout
dans les disciplines dans les
disciplines scientifiques ont avec 17
sur 590
voiliers a lu un livre écrit sur ce
sujet par une femme médecin remarquable
que j'avais reçu dans mon émission à
france culture
alors souvent
expliqué en les cas américain par
exemple que les femmes avaient du mal à
trouver des places dans les laboratoires
et leur travail était souvent récupérés
soit par le mari soit par responsables
de laboratoires ne peut pas dire que le
prix nobel était entre guillemets
sexistes dès l'origine je vous rappelle
que marie curie la lueur 1903 elle est
deux fois
menaçant 3911 une fois en physique il
faut en chimie donc ne pas dire que que
les femmes aient du mal dès le début à
avoir le prix nobel ce qui était pas le
cas pour l'académie par exemple pour
d'autres institutions scientifiques
maintenant
si vous regardez les photos des
laboratoires
des années d'entre deux guerres ou bien
d'après la deuxième guerre mondiale il
ya très peu de femmes donc il ya un
effet statistique
et les applications plus profondes à mon
avis on sont moins liées peut-être à la
façon dont on fait de la physique ou de
la scion dans les laboratoires qu'otis
positif de l'éducation dans son ensemble
comment est-ce qu'on traite entre
guillemets les filles dans les classes
pendant les cours de sciences c'est
plutôt ça mon avis qui a été un frein
aujourd'hui en train de se rattraper
mais qui a joué un rôle très fort tout
au long du xxème siècle
du coup vous êtes professeur et vous
avez été jury de la conférence nationale
sur l'évaluation à l'école en 2014 donc
vous devez avoir du tout j'ai fait mes
recherches dont vous devez avoir pas mal
de connaissances autour de l'éducation
comment vous pensez qu'on peut améliorer
justement l'éducation de nos jours et
notamment dans les études supérieures
pour accueillir plus de filles moi ça
m'a beaucoup intéressé 2 d'animer cette
conférence nationale parce que justement
on a auditionné des experts
expert dans une discipline qui a terminé
son travail
et mais qui n'est pas reconnue qui est
la docimologie
c'est la science de l'évaluation
et on a écouté des spécialistes et moi
ils m'ont ils m'ont retourné c'est à
dire qu'ils m'ont fait prendre
conscience du fait que il ya vraiment un
problème
avec l'évaluation avec les notes non
c'est pas une note qui sont un problème
c'est la façon de les utiliser c'est
qu'une bonne évaluation
c'est à la fois
une mesure
mesure de la qualité d'un travail fourni
par un élève est en même temps un
message un message en plus de la bio
donc si vous avez 12 est ce que vous
êtes capable de tout sur 20 est ce qu'on
est capable de dire pourquoi vous avez
donc on n'est pas 13 est ce qu'un prof
qui met 12 c'est exactement pour que la
miilos que veut dire 12
c'est jamais très bien vu et donc le
message doit être aussi vous avez eu
d'où cette fois ci et voilà ce qui vous
a manqué pour avoir 13 pour voir 14
voilà sur quoi vous devriez travailler
et ça c'est des messages qui manque
souvent et d'autre part
les spécialistes ont mené toutes sortes
d'expériences qui montre que dans la
façon d'évaluer il ya de multiples biais
que les professeurs doivent connaître
pour que leur évaluation soit juste par
exemple
il est démontré qu'un élève bout d'un
certain temps produit produit alors vous
n'avez pas aimé le mot mais je leur
prends quand même produit des
performances
qui sont conformes à sa réputation qui
sont conformes à sa plage s'il a la
réputation d'être mauvais en math il va
rater vas y vas être mauvais en math il
va il va en quelque sorte confirmé par
ces épreuves
ce qu'on pense de lui
et ça c'est un système extrêmement
pernicieux qui a été mis en évidence de
multiples façons notamment vous avez
raconté une expérience
qui m'a tellement surpris car je suis
allé voir les publications pour vérifier
que c'était bien passé comme ça vous
prenez sont élèves
qui ont un taux 10 ans de 6e qui ont la
réputation d'être mauvais en maths
et puis dans la salle d'à côté vous en
prenez sent qu'ils ont la réputation
d'être bon
vous leur dites voilà vous allez
regarder une figure qui ont germé de
riga s'est compliquée pendant cinquante
secondes
et ensuite vous allez la reproduire de
mémoire sur une feuille donc la regarder
et puis voilà désigné
alors si vous dites aux élèves qui ont
la réputation d'être de mauvais élèves
en mathématiques
aujourd'hui vous avez bien compris qu'il
s'agit d'un exercice de géométrie
là ils vont faire des choses assez
mauvaise
si on additionne des sources il aurait
dit c'est une épreuve de dessin ils font
des choses aussi bonne que les bons
élèves à qui on a dit que c'était une
épreuve de géométrie
c'est là que la façon de présenter une
évaluation de conditionner voilà
détermine résultats et pour les
différences hommes-femmes il ya des
incidents du même type qui ont été
faites y compris chez des femmes élèves
ingénieurs donc dans des grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs qui s'appelle son bandeau
maths
mais sur certains types d'exercice
quand on leur dit pas les filles font si
bien que les garçons dans la
présentation des exercices et des vieux
stéréotypes qui se manifestent
c'est quoi l'intelligence
tout cas c'est pas le qi
vous avez regardé notre émission avec
tullow élections
je crois pas je le ferai mais j'ai déjà
entendu je les ja vu déjà mais non je
pense qu'à l'intelligence et c'est
l'intelligence elle comprend l'émotion
et comprend l'empathie elle comprend
elle peut être nul en calcul
l'intelligence
on peut être très intelligent et ne pas
savoir calculer
donc c'est compliqué à définir
et
donc je suis pas convaincu que les
machines
auront une intelligence général
c'est-à-dire une audience qui sont
capables de résoudre des problèmes
complexes soient pas des problèmes pour
lesquels ces machines aura été
spécifiquement éduquer et à propos d'un
terrain artificiel puisque nous allons
employer le mot je me demande si dans
nos débats franco-français nous ne
sommes pas victime d'un problème de
traduction au sens où l'intelligence en
anglais intelligence c'est pas
l'intelligence on s'en souvenir
longtemps c'est l'information en fait
renseignements le renseignement c'est
l'intelligence service donc que des
machines puissent collecter des
renseignements et les manipuler plus
rapidement et mieux que nous c'est déjà
fait c'est déjà démontré
mais c'est du renseignement
s'est pas encore ce qu'on appelle de
l'intelligence qui à mon avis présuppose
pour être pleinement rayonnante la
conscience de soi déjà
c'est quoi l'amour pour vous alors là
ça j'en sais rien ça remonte à quand les
objections mais monde
ben écoutez c'est bon ça dure ça reste
non là je vais je guérirai sanguin
klein et ça c'est beaucoup a autorisé
c'est déjà ce n'est pas de problème l'
idée ça vous parle et danse nous donne
on ne vivrait
mais qu'est ce que je dois dire je
t'aime pardon elle doit parler ouais
carrément mai puis surtout jouer
tu vois que vraiment une question
est ce qu'on doit lui offrir la
nationalité l'asile politique
a priori comme ça sans bien connaître le
dossier je dirais oui mais il faut voir
aussi les conséquences au fait qu'on
fait
vous avez peur des crises et à la
politique un c'est quand même de voir
les conflits les conséquences aussi eu
peur des conséquences pas pour moi
évidemment mais il faut regarder si
elles sont tenables n'a pas nui
diplomatique je rêvais pas répondre à
l'emporte-pièce à des questions comme
celle là vous avez encore envie d'avoir
votre visa pour les etats unis un prix
par exemple
c'est pas grave
est ce qu'aujourd'hui au commissaire à
l'énergie atomique et aux énergies
alternatives
on envisage le nucléaire comme une des
solutions pour faire face aux
dérèglements climatiques
alors voyez bien que
c'est pas le cea qui décide de la
politique nucléaire de la france
allait décider par ailleurs ils savent a
fait des recherches pour la rendre
possible on propose des solutions
auxquelles on n'avait pas pensé qu'ils
peuvent apparaître à l'issue des
recherches qu'on y mène maintenant voyez
bien le nucléaire comme une énergie très
particulière et si on voulait produire
l'électricité mondiale
actuellement produite par le nucléaire
exclusivement
voyez le nombre de réacteurs qu'il
faudrait installer
ça suppose d'avoir des réserves de
combustible à l'uranium
l'uranium 235 qui ferait pas long feu il
faudrait prendre 238 pour faire des
réacteurs avec des neutrons un peu plus
pêchus qu'ils soient incapables de faire
fissionner d'uranium 238 et donc
non produire toute l'électricité par le
nucléaire
c'est pas possible et donc il faut
décider de la part qu'on lui accorde et
cette part elle dépend évidemment des
pays selon qu'ils sont dotés en énergie
de ce type là où d'autres types de
l'homme dépend aussi du système
politique il faut une sûreté il faut des
contrôles il faut une indépendance de la
surveillance par rapport au pouvoir
politique un somme de contraintes qui
font que le problème ne serait pas
simplement a en fait de compter les
réserves de ceci ou de cela qu'on trouve
dans la croûte terrestre des différents
pays il vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui en
france la sûreté justement de nos
centrales nucléaires et l'optimal
moi je connais pas bien ce sujet là mais
bon ça a l'air d'aller assez bien en
france quand même on peut pas dire qu'on
a eu des accidents
il ya quand même beaucoup d'heures
réacteurs cumulés sur l'ensemble du parc
101 sans incident grave maintenant moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il ya un débat sur le
clair un vrai débat un débat qui soit
un peu comme vous le proposez vous même
un débat sur la question
couplé énergie climat
qu'est ce qu'on veut comme énergie je
parle de quantités
en moyenne par habitant en france quelle
est la part d'électricité con mais là
dedans et comment nous décidons
collectivement de produire cette énergie
maintenant et pour les générations
futures on n'est pas censé répondre à la
question pour ceux qui seront là dans
3000 en
maison pour nos enfants et nos petits
enfants qu'est ce qu'on envisage parce
que il ya beaucoup de trajectoire en
matière d'énergie qui se conduit sur des
régimes balistique ces grands gros
l'électrification de la france
pour 2050 2060
c'est maintenant voilà décide c'est même
pas nos enfants qui vont la décider pour
eux-mêmes c'est nous qui la décision
pour et donc j'aimerais bien mode qu'on
ait un débat mais avant de le réclamer
vraiment je veux être sûr que ce débat
aurait eu un vraiment lieu salle on
pourra parler on pourra expliquer on
pourra faire des cures assez compliqué
sur cette question qui n'est pas simple
moi ce qui me terrorise dans les débats
c'est
un conte les pour et les contre on fait
des sondages d'opinion il n'y a même pas
eu de véritables discussions
et ça je trouve que c'est une des
des faiblesses de la démocratie quand
elle ne parvient pas à décider
collectivement de ce qu'elle souhaite
vous avez entendu parler de la z machine
way
pour la fusion
ce diable pas viable la fusion s'est pas
si dur que ça
maintenant ce qu'ils eurent c'est de
récupérer plus énergique que celle qu'on
met dans le dispositif pour faire
l'avion
plus tard il devient un peu de com dans
le fait de dire tiens on a fait des
réactions de fusion
il faut les entretenir et il faut les
faire en sorte que l'énergie qu'elles
produisent
compense largement
l'énergie nécessaire pour les produire
et là
ils luttent orium
la filière thorium pour le nucléaire de
fission le thorium
une filière intéressante mais moi je
vais regarder ça je suis pas se passer
du nucléaire mais je vais regarder ça
avec des collègues ses 20 ans avait créé
un groupe qui s'appelait le 16 n ont
donné des cours du soir sur leclerc à
l'époque où on voulait pouvoir répondre
aux questions des gens
et on avait publié d'ailleurs un livre
qui s'était intitulé le nez nucléaires
expliqué par des physiciens
on avait regardé la filière thorium en
effet et on avait vu quand même qu'il ya
des productions
qui crachent pas mal et gamma de haute
énergie c'est finir
un peu précis fiables que ceux qui
voient là et c'est quand même des
paquebots tout cela donc quand vous
changer de filière
ça demande des constantes de temps
qu'ils sont assez lents
question internet liens entre science et
spiritualité pour interrogation
tout est possible tout est possible ou
croyants du alors
science et religion science et
spiritualité
pas mal le science et spiritualité on
verra les religions juste après
bon
moi je connais des faits scientifiques
qui sont très spiritualiste si entre le
spirituel c'est un autre sens si
ritualiste ils sont intéressés par là
par les questions du mystère qui pensent
que la science ne répond
finalement qu'aux questions
scientifiques
pas aux questions métaphysiques même les
physiciens et je pense qu'ils sont
d'accord pour dire que
certes les lois physiques vous donne un
pouvoir de compréhension et
d'intelligibilité remarquable mais que
sans doute on ne connaîtra jamais le
statut des lois physiques est-ce qu'elle
existe dans le monde à ce qu elles sont
hors du monde à ce qu'elle soit
immanente est-ce qu'elles sont
transcendante est ce que les lois
l'univers était fixé au début de
l'univers ou est-ce que les dés sont
pipés voila voila je pense que les gens
sont
ouvert à ça maintenant hivernale qui
sont pas du tout spiritualiste c'est et
pour la question science et religion je
vous ferai la même réponse je connais
des physiciens je connais des
catholiques je connais des physiciens
catholique mais je ne connais pas de
physique catholique
est la une
le particule de dieu voilà mes parti de
dieu c'est un problème de traduction
vous savez c'est un gag c'est un prix
lomé américain qui s'appelle et norman
qui avait voulu convaincre
l'administration américaine de la
nécessité de construire une machine un
accélérateur pour découvrir le boson de
higgs il avait intitulé son lit de 2go
dame particules cette sacrée particules
et l'éditeur voulant davantage vendre ce
livre a changé le titre en levant la
dame de coeur scintille c'était juste un
jeu de mot vous abordez le boson de
higgs
bombardé quelques choses et voir une
trace d'une autre qui ne devrait pas
exister ou qui est qui est absente qui
est dans le vide
quelle quelle perception ça c'est un
général chez vous
gbagbo ont dit que pour moi c'est là une
des plus belles choses qu'on ait faite
au xxème siècle un rêve un génial même
pour la détection
quand même que les mathématiques
conduisant physique soit capable d'agir
comme ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
treuil ontologique là on est capable de
créer dire à partir d'arguments
mathématiques l'existence d'une nouvelle
sorte d'objets physiques qu'on a jamais
vu je vous rappelle que le boson de
higgs est écrit mathématiquement parce
qu'on appelle un champ scalaires on
n'avait jamais vu ça donc on a découvert
on a prédit une nouvelle sorte d'objet
cet objet on a pu le détecter
indirectement on a pu le reconnaître
dans un
collisionneur enfin grâce à un
collisionneur on l'a reconnu parce qu'on
reconnaissait un pour reconnaître une
partie vous déjà la connaître et ça je
trouve ça époustouflant d'autant plus
que pour la faire apparaître on a dû
extraire de vide quantique en déposant
de l'énergie dans le monde quantique et
on l'a détecté par les signatures des
particules en lesquelles cette particule
c'est un acte et s'est désintégré donc
je sais pas si vous voyez toutes les
médiations qu'il faut pour pouvoir dire
tiens on l'a eu et ça veut dire qu'on
est entré en contact avec un réel
qui est un réel
très lointain du réel
proche empirique macroscopique et qu'on
soit capable
d'entrer en relation avec ce réel là je
trouve que
c'est très émouvant et 5 dit des choses
intéressantes sur l'intelligence humaine
voilà partis fille ciel humaine se dit
cool et j'avais moi si j'avais je
trouvais dommage qu'en 2012 on quand on
a annoncé la découverte on n'est pas
passé plus de temps à expliquer
on aurait dû passer plusieurs journées à
tout arrêter pour simplement écouter des
gens expliqué en détail on détaille ce
canton est ce qui explique en trois
minutes on comprend rien plus c'est
court plus incompréhensible et donc
qu'il faudrait qu'on trouve des
occasions de vraiment à expliquer en
détail l'histoire de cette découverte et
ses implications
combien de temps il vous faut pour
expliquer le boson de higgs petite
semaine non non je pense qu'on 3h
trophée cinq ans
4h50
moi quand j'ai quatre heures vu quatre
heures comme
bientôt
avec plaisir la question d'internet je
sors un livre là dans le quinze jours
qui s'appelle matière à contredire
ou il ya sept chapitres dont un qui
s'appelle les leçon philosophique d'un
petit buzz ont
placé le boson de higgs
voit sa question internet
le déterminisme est elle une religion
n'a pas de réseau région
d'abord pour les équations de la
physique classique sont déterministe les
équations de la physique quantique sont
déterministe mais quand on fait une
mesure et le hasard qui intervient
maintenant le déterminisme c'est pas la
même chose que la prédictibilité
ses basques un système est régi par des
équations déterministe qu'il et
prédictible
théorie du chaos par exemple système à
trois corps c'est la ji par les
équations déterministe mais on sait pas
prédire ce que ça va donner au monde un
temps très long mon fonds à trois ans et
sa
gestion
la théorie des champs unifiée
masini marmaille
prénom et je n'ai pas étudié non non
mais bon il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
prétendent unifiée si vous voulez c'est
que sélection la théorie du tout une
théorie du tout c'est pas une théorie de
tous
donc qu'est ce qu'on appelle une terreur
du tout la façon plus modeste et non pas
une théorie qui décrit tout la biologie
le statut de noix juridique
la météo c'est grâce à une théorie qui
est celle d'unifier dans une même
représentation mathématiques la
description des quatre interactions
fondamentales la gravitation les forces
nucléaires et la france les trois
minutes sa peau des tas de problèmes
épistémologique d'abord si on a une
théorie dite du tout à quoi
reconnaîtront connaîtra-t-on qu'elle est
bien du tout qui lui manque que rien
comme on pourrait l'attester
est-ce qu'elle sera intelligible comment
la démarquer d'autres théories qui se
prétendrait ses concurrentes
est on sûr qu'elle est complète n'at-on
rien oublié comment la tester
on arrive à la fin 20h38 on pose
toujours la même question
nous inviter ses dessins et conseils
plonger les jeunes générations parce que
vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
trop facile de donner des conseils
c'est une réponse
mais je bouge c'est pas moi je sais tu
pas un conseil mais je pense que
l'avenir sera beau
au sens existentiel du terme c'est pas
au bon sens au charmant et agréable mais
l'avenir sera beau pour les gens
courageux
quand je dans quel sens courageux c'est
à dire
prêts à sacrifier non non non encourager
pas le sens où c'est forcément et prêles
au combat
ce que moi j'appelle le courage c'est
c'est tout simplement
linverse de la lâcheté
oui c'est pareil c'est pas une idée
grandiloquente que affronter que je
défends la affronter voilà on n'attaque
pas les gens dans le dos voilà on est
courageux au sens le plus basique du
terme et dans toutes les facettes de sa
vie je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'on qu'on ne doit pas pouvoir
regretter quand c'est bien fait quoi
on peut gratter quelques minutes vous
êtes vraiment tendu mais quelle heure g
20h39 bon allez quelques minutes
quelques minutes je courais en retour
est ce qu'aujourd'hui on a encore des
arguments pour continuer à manger les
animaux
à park le coup
[Musique]
bon là on a quand même beaucoup faire
donc on peut
arguer que ça fait partie de notre
histoire et
c'est que peut-être aussi construit
grâce aux
est ce que c'est une raison pour
continuer non
moi je mange de la viande je vous le dis
franchement pas beaucoup moins qu'avant
mais j'en mange je m'interroge voilà je
m'interroge
l'interrogent par le fait que
je sais pas si c'est une illusion que je
fabrique moi-même mais
bon je suis pas mal de sports
d'endurance disons de montagne chose
comme ça il arrive toujours un moment où
j'ai l'impression quand il veut quand il
a été pas mal malmené par l'effort
physique que le corps nous fait sentir
ce dont il a besoin
et moi la rive que mon corps me signifie
que j'ai besoin d'une entrecôte
c'est à dire
je suis précise rgc pas que j'apprends
vie d'une entrecôte
séjour d'avoir besoin d'une entrecôte
pour me reconstruire
donc je m'interroge là dessus c'est
qu'on pourra manger moins on pourrait
changer évidemment les conditions de vie
dans les abattoirs et dans les circuits
qui y mène et caetera mai
je me sens pas prêt pour militer là à ce
qu'on a interrompu toute consommation
animales dans l'alimentation humaine
c'est qu'il ya énormément d'athlètes qui
sont vegan et qui se porte très bien je
sais bien j'écoutais ont ce sport c'est
l'ultra trail un an qu'ils sont tous
vegan ils sont tous sans gluten et
cetera je vois bien ça mais mais pour le
coup je ne suis pas là dedans je
m'interroge sur la part de mimétisme
dans cette mode et sur la part d'un
joueur ou commerciale dans le fait
qu'elle soit aussi à la mode cette mode
voilà je pose des questions moi je sais
qu'on peut très bien vivre en étant
mégane c'est pas ça que je le remets en
cause
je m'interroge sur ma capacité à le
devenir ce qui est une autre question
alors on va poser la dernière
que penser de la théorie du de la double
causalité de fil qui ment
c'est une théorie
intéressante mais
est ce que c'est une théorie cdrs que ça
peut être testé ou est ce que c'est une
façon de penser le lien entre temps
physique étant psychologique
cercle moi je me pose la question
depuis peu qui légitime a parlé du temps
parce que c'est les philosophes parce
que c'est les physiciens est-ce que
c'est notre façon de nous dire par le
langage ordinaire qui contient la vérité
du temps est ce que c'est les historiens
ce que ces biologistes
et je pense que la réponse qu'on peut
donner à cette question n'est pas très
clair on envie de dire c'est les
physiciens parce qu'ils ont mathématisée
le temps on en fait une variable
opératoire de la physique grâce à
laquelle la physique est devenue très
efficace mais en même temps newton qui
le premier a parlé de temps physique le
paramètre ut il dit pas pourquoi il l'a
appelée temps ce paramètre qui dans
l'ensemble pas autant qu'il aurait pu
l'appeler autrement et s'il allait
appeler autrement on a dérogerai pas les
tunisiens sur le temps
donc donc moi je la question je poserai
en réponse à votre question
c'est est ce que il est dans
l'escarcelle de la physique
d'expliquer non seulement le temps
physique s'il existe mais aussi notre
perception du temps physique
autrement dit est-ce que les questions
relatives à la conscience sont des
questions pour physiciens
ou bien est ce que ce sont des questions
qui vont réclamer pour être bien traité
d'autres disciplines que la physique
vous avez vu vous avez vu le film
premier contact ouais
bah c'est pas mal c'est pas mal mais tim
cain merci
merci pour ce premier contact il ya de
plus grand plaisir